you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the millions of
homes at risk because of extreme weather
events made worse through climate change
our more money for clean energy in
developing countries could help slow
global warming
[Music]
and the campaigner who took on big banks
over their financing of coal projects
and won
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
coming up the simple switch
which could save more than a million
tons of co2
but first more than eight million homes
could be lost every single year around
the world
because of extreme weather events made
more likely because of climate change
research from the charity shelter box at
northumbria university found that if
these events continue to increase at
existing rates
167 million homes could be lost
by 2040. that's the equivalent of every
home
in the uk being wiped out six times over
and looking specifically at the uk
according to the government five
million properties are at risk of
flooding from rivers
or the sea with me now is sam
stricanthan chief executive of
shelterbox hello to you sad thanks very
much for being
with us i mean what those numbers do is
set out in the clearest terms the human
cost but when you think of climate
change
it's not always the first thing that
springs to mind
that's right sarah it's often we focus
on the natural world and of course
that's important and
animals are also helpless but the
reality is that we're forgetting that
the impact of climate change has already
arrived for many human beings and
communities around the world
and that's where shelter box has been
working after floods
droughts and so many other
weather-related emergencies that
are human-centered they're not natural
disasters they're human-created
disasters the scale
of the impact of this it's often hard
for us to get our head around isn't it
let's look at on an individual level at
that human cost and some of the people
that you've had to help
yes the tragedy is that we can lose
sight of individual stories in the
numbers when especially when you get
into the millions for example
um one lady whose story still sticks
with me is sagarika
in india who was
devastated her family lost their home
after cyclone unfunded last year
and that reached winds of 185 million
uh sorry 185 miles an hour and it meant
that not only did she lose her home
she lost two bags of rice that they'd
collected that was soaked
and they lost their livelihood and
thanks to us at least they were able to
have emergency shelter but not only did
she
get that she also had the need for
permanent disaster resilient housing
which was simply
something that the world is not paying
enough attention about
the other issue is that she's been
living there 25 years
and year on year she has seen the
weather worsening and this is not normal
this is not natural this is being caused
by
climate change and it's tied to our
emissions and our
choices we make so sagarika's story is a
tragedy we were
able to help her in the short term her
long-term future is really dependent
on the choices and actions we make to
provide
better futures and lower emissions all
around the world
plenty for leaders to think about with
the g7 summit and cop 26 coming up sanj
thanks very much indeed
thank you in today's other climate news
world leaders are arriving this evening
for the g7 summit in cornwall
the event promised to be the first
carbon neutral g7 meeting will be
attended by leaders from canada
france germany italy japan the uk
and the us the group of seven will
discuss ways for their countries to
tackle climate change
a large oil slick from the fire damage
container ship that sunk off the coast
of sri lanka
has been photographed for the first time
satellite images show evidence of oil
seeping from the wrecked vessel
increasing fears of the environmental
impact of the disaster the ship was
carrying hundreds of barrels of
chemicals
as well as plastic pellets when it
caught fire last month
the oil and gas company shell will
accelerate its plans to cut
carbon emissions the announcement
follows a ruling by a dutch court last
month
that found the company had insufficient
plans to meet climate goals
chief executive ben van burden said that
the oil giant will rise to the challenge
but added he felt disappointed that
shell was singled out
the uk's first fully electric coach
dubbed the carbon battle bus
has been launched today it marks the
start of a zero zero-carbon tour
across the uk which aims to showcase
climate-friendly initiatives
and sustainable journeys the trip will
end at the cop 26 climate summit in
glasgow in november
halogen light bulb sales will end this
september
as part of the uk's wider efforts to
tackle climate change
halogen bulbs are far more energy
intensive than led alternatives
which last five times longer and produce
the same amount of light
but use up to 80 percent less power
the shift is expected to cut co2
emissions by 1.26 million tons
equivalent to removing half a million
cars from uk roads
and landowners are being offered grants
to create woodlands
the 15.9 million pound england woodland
creation offer
can be used to cover all the costs of
planting trees and maintaining woodlands
for 10 years the scheme aims to create
woodlands with a range of tree species
to help store carbon and tackle climate
change with extra money allocated for
woods that the public can access
let's take you over to our data
dashboard now and look at the real-time
power mix
in great britain at the moment you can
see that 29
of electricity is coming from fossil
fuels 49
from renewable sources and 22 percent
from nuclear
and there's been huge investment in
clean energy in the uk and other
developed countries
in recent years that isn't the case
everywhere
a new report from the international
energy agency says the world's climate
future
depends on developing economies
transitioning to cleaner energy
and the investment to help them do so
should be a top priority
emerging and developing economies
account for two-thirds of the world's
population
but have only a fifth of global
investment in clean energy
they currently heavily rely on fossil
fuels for their power
if you have a look at the bottom of the
chart you can see that last year the
vast majority of energy in emerging and
developing economies
was produced by coal oil or gas
in 2020 less than 150 billion us dollars
were spent on clean energy investment in
these countries
but for the world to reach its net zero
targets the iea says
this figure needs to increase by a
factor of seven to more than a trillion
dollars by
2030. let's bring in tony tier ceo of
renewables africa who work with
governments
and businesses to install solar capacity
hello to you tony
a big investment in the uk in renewables
but how easy is it to access that
investment in the places where you work
well i think it's quite difficult to
access those investments because
most of the time what we see is the
investment goes into major economies but
when it comes to an emerging market
it's not that easy to get it for simple
reason that that investment
i would say investors are not maybe
attracted enough by emerging markets
because of the perceived risk regarding
the uh currency risk or maybe the uh
polit political stability so that's why
we are seeing some issues with regard to
emerging markets and specifically africa
so not just financial hurdles but
political ones as well
uh yes not financial but also political
and i would add as well
regulatory because you need to have an
environment that is conducive for
for renewables to happen and i also
wanted to say there is a divergent in
terms of the vision
the way africa sees the fight against
climate change and the way
partners of africa will see that so
there is a disconnect there the iaea
says there needs to be a massive
increase in investment in clean energy
by 2030. how likely is that to happen do
you think
so there's a two way to look at it so if
we're looking at the
mindset that has driven us for the last
20 years or so definitely i would say
it's
very unlikely to happen however if we're
talking about the
covet spirit that has brought nation
together
and get them to spend trillions just to
make sure that they can save the planet
it's definitely possible to do it within
the next year or two i think so so
that's what i would say
and what's your message as g7 leaders
get together this week then tony
so the question would be first of all we
need to agree on what is the vision that
should be driving everybody
because as i say if there is a
disconnect and people not leaving
or not looking at the same direction i'm
more than certain that in 10 years time
we're gonna arrive but the question is
are we going to all arrive at the same
point
so the vision is important and we need
to have a vision that africa share or
emerging market share
and the vision that g7 shares or in all
of that about to save the planet
that's what i would say tony great to
hear from you thank you
you're welcome now ahead of the g7
meeting later on this week and the cop
26 summit in glasgow in november
have been renewed calls for banks to
stop financing new
coal projects as we've been hearing the
fossil fuel remains the world's
primary source of energy especially in
those developing countries
one person trying to change this is lucy
pinson whose activism successfully
pressured banks and insurance companies
in france
to stop funding new coal projects and
companies
my name is lucy panson i'm the founder
and director of reclaimed finance
i've been an activist for social justice
and against human regulation since
the end of my high school but it's when
i joined
social movements in paris in 2011 that i
really started working on
the deeper structural causes of
inequalities along the beams between
social and environmental injustice
it's really about making sure that no
more financing goes to the expansion of
the code industry
we really called all french banks to
commit to stop
providing direct financing to all
gold mines or all core plans which is
something we achieved in 2015 more or
less
when we started campaigning on code in
2013 coal wasn't such a big issue
and people didn't know in france that
coal was such a big
issue on climate and on people's life
worldwide
and we really made sure that no banks no
french banks could go
to cop21 without having
a journalist asking them how do you stop
financing cold
[Music]
we are planning some activities with our
partners
worldwide to make sure that these
financial institutions
clears our portfolio on the road to
glasgow
well that's everything from us for today
tomorrow ahead of the g7 summit in
cornwall
find out the climate impact of a cornish
pasty thanks for watching
we'll see you then